welcome back okay we're talking about
Koopman operator theory and how we can
represent non-linear systems in a
special coordinate system where the
dynamics look linear this is inherently
a data-driven method now so lots and
lots of kind of machine learning and
regression techniques are used to
approximate this Koopman operator and
what I want to talk about now is a
particularly challenging set of systems
that exhibit chaos transients
intermittent phenomena and this is also
known as continuous spectrum dynamical
systems so these are dynamical systems
where the Koopman operator doesn't have
discrete eigen value spectrum but has a
continuum of eigenvalues and these are
much much harder for data-driven
representation and there's a lot of
interesting work going on in this kind
of continuous spectrum world right now
okay so this should be a movie this is
the lorentz system and it would be
rotating around and you can see kind of
that there's this mixing and folding of
dynamics the Lorenz system is a pretty
simple one of the simplest dynamical
systems that gives rise to chaos and if
you took the Fourier transform of a
signal of a measurement signal of
Lorentz for long enough you would find
that you get this continuous power
spectrum okay so it's really hard to
represent so one thing I'll tell you
about very briefly is a method we
developed a while back called the Hankel
alternative view of Koopman this is work
with Bing Josh Erica and Nathan and this
was essentially after we developed our
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics method we started thinking if I
only had limited measurements of this
chaotic system if I only had
measurements of X this first variable
and maybe it's time derivative couldn't
I build a dynamical system model that
describes this behavior and at the time
we had no idea that this was going to
come back to Koopman theory so this is
kind of an aside that came back to
Koopman and so what we did was we
assumed we had measurements of X we
built some delay coordinates so we would
build a Hankel matrix and take the
singular value decomposition and get
these eigen delay coordinates so from X
we can get this embedding that's
under some conditions and then we would
do a basic DMD regression model or a
Sindhi regression model of the dynamics
in these coordinates and we found that
you actually get a very very linear
dynamical structure even for strongly
chaotic systems in these delay
coordinates and essentially what we
realized was that these time delay
coordinates in some sense are very good
measurements for Koopman analysis so
measuring time delayed histories of my
state measurement embeds me at a
coordinate system where my dynamics look
approximately linear and if I'm embedded
in a coordinate system where my dynamics
look linear then I have found a Koopman
representation and you can use it in
this case for prediction so there's this
kind of interesting forcing signature
because this is a chaotic system so in
the white trajectory the system really
is completely linear it's a Koopman
linear system but every once in a while
there's this kind of essential
non-linearity that kicks in and tells
you you're about to switch lubes and the
Lorentz and then you go back to this
white trajectory where your linear long
story short for this chaotic
intermittent system so when I say
intermittent it intermittently switches
it turns out that time delay coordinates
give you an extremely effective
coordinate system or embedding where
Koopman linear analysis works okay so we
were really surprised and pleased that
this kind of time delay coordinate
system works so well for Koopman we gave
it this acronym havoc it sounds kind of
cool but basically it's just time delay
coordinates and then do DMD and you get
good representations of these chaotic
systems okay in the in the time since
then we've been working with Bethany
lush so Bethany works with Nathan and
myself and we've been thinking about
these continuous spectrum dynamical
systems so it's frustrated me for a long
time that you know we're developing all
of this Koopman operator theory we're
applying it to full turbulence we're
applying it to neuroscience and you know
climate all of these big nonlinear
systems where we don't know the answer
okay and I think somehow maybe a
easier to apply this to big systems
where we don't know the answer it's
frustrated me for a while that we didn't
know what Koopman says about the
pendulum I couldn't for the life of me
write down the eigenfunctions of the
pendulum in Koopman analysis and getting
a nice linear representation of this
pendulum and I remember positing this to
my colleagues a number of years ago at a
workshop maybe we should start working
on this simpler system and try to
understand this where we almost know
everything about the pendulum because I
think you know we need to understand
this before we go to really really
complicated systems and Bethenny's made
some excellent progress
understanding how Koopman applies to
simple simple systems like the pendulum
and it all comes down to this idea of a
continuous spectrum and dynamical
systems so what is a continuous spectrum
mean well if I start this pendulum in
the down position and I give it a tiny
kick there's a natural frequency it's
going to give me pure sines and cosines
at that natural frequency because it
really is very linear for small energy
but as I increase the energy the period
gets longer and longer and longer right
this thing gets slower and slower and
eventually if I go almost to the top the
period draws out and protects to
infinity okay so this period
continuously deforms the natural
frequency of this continuously deforms
as I increase energy and so there's no
discrete eigen values of the system
there's a whole continuum of eigen
values of my Koopman system these are
phase portraits and theta theta dots and
this is you know the continuum of eigen
values from the natural frequency all
the way to zero as the period along gets
to infinity okay so this continuous
spectrum system even though it's
exceedingly simple and we think we know
everything about the pendulum it's
actually quite hard to represent Koopman
eigen functions and to represent this
pendulum in the Koopman world so that's
what Bethany has been developing and
we're really happy because we
essentially learned a lot first of all
we learned things we didn't know we
didn't know and then Bethany figured out
solutions to the representation problem
and so this is all based on this kind of
Koopman auto encoder network and we're
not the only ones developing
lots of people are developing these
auto-encoder networks to represent
Koopman so you take your data you lift
it to some nonlinear representation and
you find a few latent variables or
intrinsic coordinates given by this this
this fee of X function and you make sure
that those functions can be inverted to
give you your state back that's what a
normal auto encoder does kind of a
nonlinear version of principal
components analysis but what the Koopman
auto encoder does is it essentially adds
in this little linear time stepper in
the middle to guarantee that I can
advance Y at time K to the next time
step using a linear map K so lots of us
are doing this building these Koopman
auto-encoders to find these
eigenfunctions that advance linearly in
time this is a really cool approach to
the eigen function representation
problem but what Bethany realized is
that lots of dynamical systems of
interest don't have a discrete eigen
value spectrum so there's no you know
there's no K matrix with just a plus or
minus I Omega I ghen values that will
represent the pendulum because there's a
whole continuum of eigen values for that
problem and in traditional harmonic or
perturbation analysis you need all of
these harmonics of that natural
frequency to approximate that continuous
spectrum and so we actually postulate
that a lot of these Koopman autoencoders
that people are applying to continuous
spectrum systems they need a pretty big
middle layer to approximate all of these
harmonics okay and so what Bethany is
doing instead is she builds this
auxilary side network which essentially
learns the continuous parameter value
Omega that then parameterize is that
plus or minus I Omega so we still have a
structure with two eigen functions
complex conjugate eigen functions plus
and minus we still have this Jordan
block
excuse me this Jordan block of our K
operator plus or minus I Omega eigen
values but now we have this auxilary
side network which essentially given the
the energy of the system the energy
level of the system it continuously
varies the actual
frequency so we hard code that we still
want to variables to eigenfunctions we
want them to be complex conjugate so we
build that structure into this K matrix
but Bethany has this auxilary side
network which essentially parameterize
as those eigenvalues with this parameter
Omega and so it's learning the
continuous spectrum dependence on the
state X and it's learning this
eigenfunction structure and so this this
extra constraint and structure in the
system allows us to learn these much
more parsimonious representations with
kind of these minimal variables in the
middle that are now parametrized by our
exhilarate at work and she's applied
this to the the pendulum problem and
she's essentially found these
eigenfunctions in phase space that when
you map into these coordinates you get
perfect sines and cosines perfect linear
behavior at different frequencies for
different amplitudes so different you
know the farther you go out and radius
you still have sines and cosines but now
the frequency changes and after talking
to egor message he pointed out that you
can actually map these into magnitude
and phase coordinates and there's this
really beautiful connection to these
action angle coordinates from classical
mechanics that you can read about in his
archive paper from 2017 so that was kind
of a fun connection we made you know we
showed this to Igor and he pointed out
if we map it in this coordinate system
we basically get action angle
coordinates for this pendulum which is
really really nice and satisfying
because that connects us back to this
kind of hundred years of or more than
100 years of classical mechanics and
again it all relies on this auxilary
network of parameterizing this or else
we wouldn't have been able to get to
eigenfunctions we would have had all of
these harmonics plus or minus two I
Omega plus or minus three I and I got
four you know all of those harmonics
would have been necessary here okay so
she's also applied this to more rich
systems like the flow past a cylinder
which also has this continuous
deformation of my eigenvalues as I
increase or decrease the energy level of
the system so she finds these
eigenfunctions here that mapped me into
a linear coordinate system so it's
this method scales because it is relying
on the power and flexibility of this
this deep learning architecture okay so
those are just a couple of the many
approaches people are starting to play
with for continuous spectrum dynamical
systems so it turns out maybe maybe
other people knew this but I didn't
appreciate even two years ago how
ubiquitous the continuous spectrum is
and dynamical systems most of the
systems of interest to me that I'm
interested in have a continuous spectrum
they don't just have discrete eigen
values they have this continuous
deformation of the eigenvalues over you
know in energy or control inputs and so
I think this is only going to become
more and more important to start
thinking of how our Koopman
representation applies to these
continuous spectrum systems and
currently I think two of the leading
methods are time delay coordinates so
lots of us are now looking at the
mathematical theory and the applied use
of delay coordinates for Koopman
representations of these chaotic systems
and then the other broad category for
representing these nasty kind of Koopman
systems are deep networks deep neural
networks autoencoders parametrized
autoencoders it's a hard representation
problem and deep learning is tailor-made
for hard representation problems if you
have enough data okay so hopefully these
keep developing and keep emerging to
solve these more and more realistic
continuous spectrum problems okay thank
you